Hello 今天是本黄皮平时素严的时候最爱用的几只扣红分享
我这个人比较懒
就是喜欢那种不需要什么技巧
所以变图图就很好看很显泄色的那种
我是带你人黄一百
这几只都是我今天要细选出来的新头号
绿色无关大家可以放兴使用
第一只就是阿拉钢
这只就是我图图之后我们工作室的姐妹全部都买了
真的不是广告它比我活
全面很好看
我喜欢保图
但我对方说是一个很有缘气
很有气忍眼色
很清透的红茶冬的感觉
而且不需要什么技巧
这就是随便图一下就很美丽了
怎么样
现在跟我开始素严的时候
是不是整个人的气色完全不错呢
这只真的我第一个可能跟着想
我真的很喜欢它
这一只它就很像阿拉钢的皮皮
这两个颜色有点像包图后的多很精彩
它这个上纵嘴的圈地
也是很适合干纯的
一上纵就感觉
你画开在你的嘴上
怎么样是会跟刚才的阿拉钢非常像
就是一直搞定你的气色的感觉
我过这种治地的缺点
就是不沉默
以后就掉
但是很好看
我们可以多不不
这个是RCE这个系列
我个人最爱的意志
它是这种带有一点宗调的红茶色
非常显白
熬图就很适合我们黄皮素严
很有气血感
而且因为它保图
没有那么高
所以还蛮显白的
厚图的话应该会更适合秋冬
其实它还是一直多用帮过
同时画装手小白
它图在脸架这边当赛红
看起来整个人的气色特别好
这一只真的超适合黄皮
把我图就是很靠看的
无花果色掉
很低保和显溫柔的个影子
厚图的话会多一些红宗调写的
更有气质一些
我昨天一般都是这样保图
若若地不会把干净
很丝了吧
很好推开
味道我不是特别喜欢
有点工业相
但是甚在便宜
这一只是真正的
味素研控红
但但相当习是过一定的每回色
放嘴是弄弄的
我每次素研拍顶的时候
若若地当惊的气色不是特别好
我就会图这一只口红
所以它算得上是我的新机神器
它会有一点微微的认则感
但不会太亮也没有什么水光感
就好像是一本身
你天身就是这个纯色一样
但它这个颜色确实比较前的
身纯节没要盖一下戴头
这一只是MFC314
老网红了
有点性纸色料的密桃色
黄体是和保图
护图的话会有眼影光感
对着我跟着很喜欢
粉举粉举的有一点奶护护的纸感
很乖和温柔
但这只就不太适合生存的剪的意义
这一只应该是我这个黄膝
一只没纸色料的扣红红红
但是我回够的第三层
我一般素研就这样
剪了一点
然后把它银开
它有一点点不好和温柔的效果
既看真的很像一个水洞不浪
它应该是一只染沉业
就沉默之后是不会沾杯的
不太沉
有一点点
我喜欢它的点就是非常地持久
就我拖它之后
我一天都不用担心上我的嘴上
都没有颜色
但缺点也是它非常地难谢
而且也会比较挑成
不能状态
如果嘴上有很多死体的话
途它大概会突破云
但是没有办法
它真的很美
而且用它打体之后
后面再图一些
交通过我一点的那种纯密
也会很好看
好的 今天的分享
就结束了非常感谢
大家能看到这里
我们被重草了哪一只呢
其实这是我第一次拍口红分享
大家有什么意见都可以跟我说
然后还有什么想看我分享的
都可以留言告诉我
我还有很多很多的口红可以拍的